when they were sending me about sasso
and Lily or sending me pictures of my
net worth which is wrong but they at
first they said I was worth 200 grand
then they say I'm worth 1/5 or something
but it's a picture of you when you were
like 26 Jesus crazy you know that Bryan
Callen put into Bryan Callen Network and
you see net worth it here's a seat
Brendan Schaub someone said it's the
same as Rogan to when he klieg on row
against a picture of me people are crazy
that's right I'll never change it
beverage there's umbrella you can
apparently girls were looking at you and
I we were at scopa and and we were
eating you and I and apparently these
two girls clocked us at the bar and
thought we were hot and they they were
looking at us and they they googled our
net worth the bartender told me and you
came up at 6 million or something and I
came up with 200,000 and they go well
the old guys pour so [ __ ] that and they
decided they weren't gonna come over and
talk to us what cuz we thought the poor
guy went to help on that Marco told me
that Margo's man she was like ah he's
poor to Iran he's 50 years old la fare
like I know there was a lock that guy
what about the young one who's loaded
yeah but no but then because they were
fighting about who got you and their I
don't want the [ __ ] I don't wanna
deal with the old brokedown how are
wrinkles and and shingles
I don't want wrinkles and shingles I
don't want wrinkles and change a lady
laying handle both wrinkles the old man
watch yeah we take him out he can take
two you worry about he goes ok not
contagious good jack off in the corner
to us [ __ ] hilarious
you're not getting away in LA two
hundred thousand dollars Oh God who cool
so in saying that word thank God those
skanks ain't come by well I thank God it
says I'm worth 200 grand I'll keep it
just like that
Tony Jeffries uh wife Sarah she says
she's got another promotion got her
master's so now she's like the queen bee
of nurses and I was like I can't imagine
some the stories and she goes awesome
the stories for at dinner this is the
other day at sushi she was some of the
stories well last week I was working at
midnight and this gentleman came in goes
I don't feel good I fell and I think
something got stuck in my rectum Wow
oh you fell guess what the x-ray showed
Oh we'll be a tide detergent bottle a
tide bottle like you don't want those
small egg down I bought like your skinny
sure had a my
he just fell yeah and it went up his
rectum rectum well sometimes something
have to get it out
no sometimes if you have a tied to
tourism bottle and there's a lot of Lube
on it and you're running by and you pull
your [ __ ] open super hard like you
take your I call it peeling the peach
you've got your hooker you hook your
fingers right at the right right where
where your button hole open lobster-claw
nope and then you just and then it just
you've fallen just be that smaller one
there's Eddie
they went well we need gets our you're
gonna die he's like yeah I don't know
what happen I'll just they're animals up
there as well and then she said she also
another gentleman came in you know those
like the twenty ounce coke bottles I was
stucked up his old pooper I really can't
get it out though and then uh she said
the one guy with the the coke bottle up
his anus it was there for six days well
that's not good he goes I just thought
I'd pass it she's like no you cannot go
a message in your rump that way or
kratom if you want just keep it in glass
there's all kinds of things you can do
with your with your bum I didn't know
that the the old caboose could carry a
tide bottle oh the caboose clearing
body's pretty impressed
yeah the caboose can carry a shitload my
fist all kinds of things yeah yeah a
bunch of cash fat dick thousand dollars
and rolled $100 bills probably a million
dollars if you're really really what you
do in Hawaii brother run run hard in the
did you know the guy that just chills
out in the Sun I'm gonna cut through the
water like I you ever see me swim and do
the butterfly yeah I have kaduche I get
up hey hop it you guys have activities
playing are you just gonna chill though
are you that you don't feel like that
I'll go on vacation I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna veg out at like a you know
that are you gonna do I'll be restless
alright I'll play with my kids well my
daughter won't play with me my son will
my daughter will did I get away from me
especially in shorts because you're
disgusting and don't embarrass me but my
son will play with me yeah so that'll be
cool and then I'll I will do stuff you
know I I held a little tiger down
because he's getting this straight fro
I'm like this here at he went he's a
hundred percent 2471 so he's sweating
he kept his the hair was like getting
his face I'm like we gotta cut his hair
and he hates [ __ ] clippers so I have
Joe home down I shaved his head to say
ah I gotta see a picture I'm acting a
little better
oh my god and then I I sent this our
friends were over and they're like do
you really get his legs look at this
[ __ ] kid man
dude that's the craziest he looks like a
crossfit out no I'm not kidding these
giant quads on him what does he is he
now is he's squatting over 200 pounds
I'm not kidding that's I know can we
were obviously I kick what's going on
I'm like is I sweet he's I don't give
him any gun traps
those legs are stupid little shaved head
I mean he's got it just his leg looks
like the letter S think of the letter S
he's got giant quads and then they go
into these his calves are every bit as
big as Will Sasso yes and then you could
rest a beer bottle up on his ass that
goes all the way out and he's how old
it's two men that's the nuttiest thing
I've ever seen in my life and he's got a
mound of pubic hair goatee is that what
you're doing give him steroids man we're
trying to go to the league maybe it's
the hormones and the meat but not trying
to go to the league that's so weird
he's got a full beard he's got a tape
Fletcher beard get out the hood man it's
kind of crazy you can't rap get a ball
got a ball you got a ball son you got
stabbed Ullman it was attacked in Flores
she went missing
oh and she was walking her two dogs and
then she went missing and then later on
people found out that there's just huge
croc or alligator in this area in
Florida and they were they found the
alligator and then opened them up and
found an arm inside oh [ __ ] so it eight
is eight her arm and they found the body
like a daily I don't they'll twist your
arm off and swallow that it's for the
body so they find they find time yeah
but also I saw something on this too
that that neighborhood they the
homeowners association
sent out a whole warning how on one's
alligators every we know then apparently
attacked her from behind so she was
walking and it just somehow crept up
oh my god that's so scary how old was
she though 47 not battles thank you
would be tough to hear that Gator
tracking lizard gets behind you and
grabs you and it takes you in oh my god
that would be so [ __ ] scary well foot
so that's a yeah that's a huge animal
let me see this is terrifying I think
they showed footage of it from this
afternoon from a chopper like the
alligator swimming there it is
seven-year-old Shizuka Matsutani tastes
flesh that's the problem a wildlife a
foot this is my thing though if you move
to Florida
norman's alligators doing alligator [ __ ]
man well it's pretty rare what you don't
expect the homeowners association sends
out a warning goes hey yeah hey man
around this round you stay on the path
so we're not [ __ ] no is that if I come
home today and they're like hey did you
see the memo on the front door what's
the memo bro there are [ __ ] lions
wandering around here just stay down
this road though but they are around but
in floor I would not go outside Florida
you can carry a pistola I'm carrying
ain't gonna do [ __ ]
I've carried what I'm carrying me my my
pistola you grab me alligator grabs me I
pull out my pistol ax and I and I
unloading this holdup John says he had a
brain yourself pretty undertaking
campaign telling people not to feed
alligators as they might lose their fear
of humans which could lead to more
attacks yep so stop bringing out that
raw chicken and slap in the water all
right guys